dévoilé à Nikos Aliagas alors je vous
montre une photo d'Amel Bent je vous
montre là qu'attelle des volets Nikos
Aliagas un indice non j'en ai pas elle a
dit une phrase je le sais donc je vais
pas le dire
dans le portrait 50 Minutes Inside elle
a elle a dévoilé beaucoup de choses et
ben elle a parlé de son poids elle a
parlé aussi du fait que quand elle était
petite elle a vécu des moments très
difficiles et que si elle avait son
enfant à côté d'elle son petit enfant
intérieur elle avait plein de choses à
lui dire
le sujet
elle a dit qu'elle avait traversé des
moments un petit peu difficiles que
parfois il y avait eu des sessions de
2-3 ans ou l'argent de rentrait pas et
elle a dit je ne gagne pas aussi bien ma
vie parfois que ce que vous pourriez
croire parfois pendant deux ans il n'y a
rien qui rentre donc elle a dit que
c'était très difficile sa situation et
c'est vrai que ça choqué pas mal de
personnes derrière ce qu'on peut
comprendre surtout quand on a un peu les
salaires pour The Voice combien ils
gagnent sur The Voice elle gagne à peu
près 450 000 € de cachets et un petit
peu plus avec les droits d'image donc on
est proche de 500000 €. voilà à ça on
ajoute les disques bah oui
plus d'un million de disques et elle
touche combien par disque elle touche 79
centimes d'euro après ça grimpe c'est
exponentiel en fonction du nombre de
ventes donc un million d'euros par 10
voilà il faut savoir en plus que c'est
l'une des rares artistes pas pour rien
qu'on la surnommé la princesse du RNB
française qui depuis que les disques ne
se vendent plus cartonne en stream
d'accord
250 millions et ça ça lui rapporte un
million d'euros 25 ça veut dire que si
c'est le calcul on est à peu près entre
50 et 70 000 € par mois voilà ça
c'est-à-dire que même une année ou pas
on peut comprendre que ça agacé les gens
parlait pas de ça avant The Voice
finalement au moment du creux de la
vague et c'est vrai que si elle
s'habitue à un certain train de vie se
retrouver avec deux ans sans rentrer
d'argent avant de Voice et avant les
cachettes The Voice c'est peut-être un
peu plus compliqué donc non non non je
peux répondre ouais juste un truc non
c'est faux parce que elle est l'une des
rares par exemple dans son domaine à
être auteur interprète par exemple ma
philosophie c'est un million de vente
pure de single à l'époque et aujourd'hui
on en avait parlé avec Patrick Hernandez
quand il était venu quand tu es auteur
interprète tu touches à chaque fois que
ton titre parce quelque part donc Amel
Bent elle a pas d'année ou rien ne
rentre ça n'existe pas elle reste
apparemment sont quand même énorme et
comme elle est auteur comme tu viens de
le dire elle touche à chaque fois que
son disque passe et le disque il passe
énormément en radio donc elle doit quand
même avoir
question de François Hollande à partir
de combien pour vous on est riche parti
de combien par mois
10 15000 on est 10 15000 € par mois
j'aimerais bien oui mais à partir de
combien on est riche pour toi on est
riche au-dessus de 100000 non par mois
par mois oui
moi je dirais 4000 4000 comme François
Hollande
quand tu gagnes 4000 euros par mois tu
fais partie du plus petit pourcentage de
français
[Rires]
quelqu'un qui gagne 10000 € ou 15000 €
par mois à Paris il peut pas non plus
tout faire c'est pour être riche c'est
ne rien compter quand tu gagnes 10 15000
c'est énorme c'est bien au-dessus de la
majorité des personnes mais tu comptes
quand même tu réfléchis un peu à ce que
tu fais tu es pas en mode flamber
attention tu vas un peu déraper 15000 €
à Paris on est sur place
si les gens qui nous regardent tu peux
pas tu peux pas faire ce que tu veux
c'est pas vrai tu fais pas mal de choses
c'est beaucoup de vedettes aussi qui
sont endettés je citerai pas de nom
parce qu'elles ont pas compris qu'on
adapté ces revenus sont très bien sûr
qu'on oublie pas ses impôts
qu'elle avait touché 500 € comme cachet
pour venir chanter et c'est vrai bah oui
parce qu'elle avait plus d'argent du
tout là mais elle avait plus d'argent
elle avait vendu elle avait pas écrit
évidemment qu'est-ce que tu crois bah tu
chantes des grippe il y a un moment
c'est compliqué